depuis quelques années peu importe leur
taille les entreprises sont en pleine
mutation numérique les tâches manuelles
sont remplacés par des technologies
digitales et cette tendance s'accélère
avec la crise sanitaire certaines
entreprises ont même gagné sept ans sur
leur transformation numérique
[Musique]
c'est le cas d'avis l'un des leaders
français de location de voiture avec sa
nouvelle application le client n'a plus
aucun contact humain un écran remplace
l'agent d'accueil lui indique le numéro
de place de parking les clés et le
contrat sont sur le tableau de bord
est plus qu'à servir à prendre le
véhicule est à partir pas donc en fait
tout se fait directement sur
l'application donc 50 ans
pour les plus sceptiques un guichet
reste ouvert pour l'instant seuls 37%
des clients ont opté pour la version
digitale
bonjour
web permet s'il vous plaît c'est le seul
contact humain que vous avez c'est le
seul ouais en fait ils vérifient
vraiment que ça soit bien nous et qu'il
prenne notre permis et donc après y'a
plus qu'à partir
vous aussi merci au revoir
avis détient environ 500 points de
location en france ces dispositifs
numériques restent encore marginaux ces
zones ont été développées depuis trois
ans on accélère clairement aujourd'hui
on a six aujourd'hui qui sont
principalement des aéroports et des
gares c'est des investissements qui sont
entre 100 et 150 mille euros par station
à chaque fois qu'on veut mettre ses
digitalisation
l'entreprise continue d'investir et de
multiplier ces zones 2.0 partout en
france un virage numérique onéreux mais
vitale dans les années à venir
c'est encore un investissement
je pense que la rentabilité va arriver
assez rapidement parce que la
satisfaction client ramène plus de
clients la rapidité ramène encore plus
de clients donc pour nous c'est capturer
de nouveaux clients par rapport à ces
visites animations
tous les secteurs se lance dans cette
course folle la digitalisation comme
l'atelier des chefs et ses cours de
pâtisserie en ligne se dit lui sert
essentiellement de base à de très
nombreux
c'est précis l'aboutissement
marie 39 ans est juriste elle n'aurait
jamais imaginé suivre une formation de
six semaines en pâtisserie par écran
interposé ce qui paraît surprenant en
fait pour la pâtisserie parce que c'est
quelque chose de très pratique
maintenant la formation est très bien
faite parce qu'on a une partie théorique
qui on a des petites vidéos en fait qui
nous montre les gestes à acquérir mais
c'était quelque chose on a besoin de
sentir de touché mais en tout cas
d'avoir un professionnel à côté soit
vous apprenez aussi à développer vos
sens et puis on apprend aussi qu à
partir d'une photo la texture
visuellement en fait la texture va
permettre de déterminer si ces ratés ou
pas et ça on apprend en fait en le
faisant moi ça m'est arrivé et
maintenant à l'oeil je sais voir si ma
pâte à choux elle va être bonne ou si
elle va être raté la formation s'adresse
à tous peu importe le niveau et le
matériel dont on dispose en étant maman
de trois enfants le faire en présentiel
pour moi c'était pas possible en fait
c'était pas gérable avec la logistique
familiale du coup c'était un super
compromis parce que du coup je pouvais -
me mettre une fois que les enfants
étaient couchés ou quand les enfants
étaient à l'école ça me permettait de
pouvoir me consacrer à 100% à ma
formation le digital c'est
c'est la clé pour demain
et marie est loin d'être la seule
cliente satisfaites aujourd'hui le
distanti elle est devenue une réelle
industrie
donc on a plusieurs cuisines c'est
vraiment notre métier historique puisque
on fait de la formation en présentiel
avec ici des gens qui vont cuisiner plus
que de la pâtisserie quant à côté faire
de la cuisine faute de place les
formations sont limités à une quinzaine
de stagiaires pour augmenter son chiffre
d'affaires françois dû faire un choix
louer des locaux supplémentaires ou plus
improbables investir dans un plateau de
télévision
là on va voir maintenant le studio donc
là où on fait toutes nos formations
digital et donc nos formations on a une
cuisine pardon dans lesquels on va
pouvoir faire toutes nos préparations et
toutes nos vidéos de cuisine de
pâtisserie de boulangerie un pâtissier
six caméras des techniciens et des
dizaines de vidéos inédites
chaque année
[Musique]
ce qui est très important c'est que pour
faire de la formation aux vidéos
d'informations digitales il faut que la
qualité soit absolument topissime est en
fait c'est pour ça que pendant un temps
les gens avaient peur de la formation
digital c'est qu'ils avaient
l'impression que l'image et la qualité
allait être médiocre aujourd'hui avec ce
matériel là c'est du matériel
qu'effectivement on va retrouver dans
des pour faire des émissions de
télévision
aujourd'hui 5000 clients sont inscrits à
la formation en ligne des inscriptions
en perpétuelle augmentation
sur la formation digital on a fait 100 %
de croissance pendant trois ans et donc
notre enjeu c'est de multiplier par dix
neuf chiffre d'affaires dans les cinq
prochaines années en moyenne les
entreprises ayant fait le choix de la
digitalisation serait plus performante
de 26%
[Musique]